bad news guys if you own Dragon Ball Z
on DVD then it's almost certain that it
looks way worse than it's supposed to
and what do I mean by that well if you
own DBZ DVDs it's most likely you own
these ones this set is referred to as
quote the orange boxes made by
FUNimation back in the 2000s they
promised that these box sets would be
remastered experience the classic series
as it was originally intended except
well they didn't do so good the remaster
was rushed zoomed in on the footage to
make it widescreen blast color contrast
up so high my eyes hurt looking at it
and smeared a giant layer of Vaseline
over at the tri-end quote remove the
grain this box set is actually pretty
well known in the anime Community as one
of the worst home releases to ever hit
shelves but of course a lot of people
still own it and why well that's a long
story maybe for another day but a short
answer is that they're just so damn
cheap